que instant messieurs les frères jean
marc thibault comme vous allez promis
avec professionnels du salé au public
voyons vous retrouvez un petit peu non
plus n'ont même songé mais dans votre
propre rôle
alors on va vous demander de jouer un
instant pour ces demoiselles qui nous
regarde l'iphone hommes du san
le jouer
yann soit parti me huer bien voilà alors
voilà pour pour sa rentrée il a préparé
un petit compliment quand un petit poème
allez vas-y le sont pas timides
granby il choisit une femme de jean de
la fontaine qui est un de mes camarades
de la société des auteurs un ancien si
massive le corbeau et le renard
je ne vous le dirais pas je vous le
sifflerait le corbeau et le renard c'est
le fromage ça
désigné